foreign
welcome to the show that puts you at the
center of the national conversation
talking about the issues that matter to
you the most
there's never been a greater need for
transparency in politics faith in
politicians is that it's loathe ebb for
years and if they want the trust of the
people back they're going to have to
come clean about why they say and do
what they say and do
all week Sky News has been bringing you
the Westminster accounts a major project
from us here at Sky and tortoise media
showing the value of gifts given the
full scale of donations to individuals
and political parties and how much MPS
really earn tonight we'll do our best to
answer your questions and discuss the
issues raised by our investigations
I'm Trevor Phillips and this is the
great debate
[Applause]
who is paying our politicians and why
and who's benefiting from the money
flowing through our political system
the Westminster accounts allows for the
first time everyone to search by an MP's
name or a voters postcode we've shown
you who's received the most money in
earnings in this Parliament and which
donors give to individual MPS as well as
parties and which companies and people
have donated the most
we know that some MPS find this
uncomfortable they've told us so but
that's what we and our viewers panel are
here to do
tonight we'll speak to people across the
country they'll have their say and
they'll share their views
while joining us here in the studio this
week are Heather Brooke whose
groundbreaking work lifted the lid on
MP's expenses back in 2009.
James Harding the editor and founder of
tortoise media whose organization worked
closely with Skye on the Westminster
accounts
Bob kersley crossed bench pier and
former head of the Civil Service
and Henry Hill Deputy editor of
conservative home
the big question tonight the Westminster
accounts who funds your MP
who funds our politics and our
politicians there's no incentive for MPS
really to make it easy to do the sort of
comparison that you've done in this
exercise should intend please be banned
from having second jobs duck houses and
moats you couldn't make it up
to clean up the system of MP's expenses
to prevent abuse and to ensure
transparency
we are going to hold MPS to account
the more transparency the better so
everybody can see exactly what has been
declared yes we're from Sky News all
party parliamentary groups they're a big
part of the Westminster system I don't
think there is sufficient transparency
in terms of why they're doing it the
potential problem is in the lack of
transparency on funding this is our
democracy MPS are there to make laws
which govern our lives so we don't know
where the money is coming from or who's
behind that money that's a serious
threat to democracy I think transparency
is really important and that's why we
have a set of rules and regulations in
place to provide that transparency for
people and it's important that those
rules are adhered to
[Music]
let's go straight to our viewers panel
and I want to talk to Derek Watson Derek
uh I know you've got a view on this and
you've got a question for our panel go
ahead
good evening Trevor yes was politicians
fundings
actions illegal they're shrouded in
smoking mirrors which often serves to
agitate voters and incent incense public
sector workers as evidenced in the
nursing profession who are fighting for
a fair day's salary for a fair day's
work so Trevor my question is are those
who pursue a political career motivated
by the common good of the people or by
lucrative double jobbing
thank you very much Derek I like the
expression double jobbing Derek's
question for our panel is are our MPS
motivated by the common good um and
James Harding uh you almost couldn't
make this up live show
half an hour ago we learned that the
former prime minister Boris Johnson uh
has I was going to say it's trouser
that's impolite has been donated a
million pounds by somebody very rich
what do you make of it what's going on
well Derek said two things then I think
are really interesting one is smoke and
mirrors
and the nature of this whole project
is in theory about transparency and I
say in theory because the the strange
thing about the whole undertaking has
been realizing that all of these things
are declared but we can't really see
what's going on so it's it's a different
version of smoke and mirrors it's
transparency without visibility they're
telling you but you can't see what's
really going on and so what you describe
Trevor is a perfect case in point
um don't talk about double Jobing lots
of people
in Parliament who have second jobs who
have other forms of earnings actually
what you learn from the Westminster
accounts because you can rank everyone
in terms of how they earn money it is
actually a very very small number of
people who really earn a lot of money
from outside jobs they're only about you
know 20 30 people out of a you know
Parliament 650.
but then you find what you just
described which is a donation so not an
earnings a donation someone's given the
former prime minister Boris Johnson a
million pounds and this is what I mean
about the difference between
transparency and visibility we've just
seen the latest update of the register
of interests that Christopher harborne
who's uh and I don't know I'm just
literally trying to figure out who this
person is a business person apparently
based in Thailand investor in
cryptocurrencies but the truth is we
really don't know has donated a million
pounds to the quote-unquote office of
Boris Johnson what does that office do
who does it pay what is it for is it
personal is it political we just don't
know Henry um
we need to stress of course that all of
this is perfectly lawful and in fact uh
the point that James has made is that
Westminster accounts has really just
collected publicly available uh
information so there's nothing unlawful
nothing illegal here but it's murky
isn't it well I mean yeah to an extent
and certainly when you set it to
Sinister violin music
um it's going to seem even more so I
think the the important thing about this
is that there is always there is some
wrongdoing or you know there always is
people have the people in Parliament
have the same spectrum of motivations as
the rest of humankind and there will be
bad actors oh empathsen I think was an
obvious example of someone who last year
was the year before was done for
something that was quite clearly a
breach of the rules but again some of it
is entirely entirely legitimate I think
that having people working second jobs
actually sometimes enhances parliament
in at least two ways one quite
specifically I think if you look at the
numbers some of the biggest earners are
lawyers now you you know if you're a
lawyer you're taking a very big pay cut
just to become an MP so one of the top
names here Jeffrey Cox he's made a lot
of mine is a barrister absolutely former
former Attorney General and Parliament
ultimately needs lawyers to serve as Law
Officers some of the most important
people in cabinet so you know allowing
them to continue to earn a legal salary
is very useful but also it gives MPS a
degree of independence from the
government especially if they're Tory
MPS currently in the government's in
office because if you took away second
jobs the only way for an MP to really
increase their income which you know
most people want to do would be to climb
the greasy pole so yes they need to be
properly scrutinized transparency is
good but I think it's important to
remember that merely the fact of people
having second jobs is not evidence of
wrongdoing I don't think and I I I'm
gonna address this all night I don't
think anybody uh here at sky or from
tors media is saying that there is wrong
doing here I think the question here is
do we understand quite what it is that's
going on one question that um Henry's
race had is this issue and Derek talked
about double Jobing
lots of people do more than one job you
know portfolio existence is it
right from MP do you think it's it
worked for MPS
it's really I mean yes I think for the
reasons that Henry said that you want
experienced people to be in Parliament
and you want them to be from as broad a
range of skills as possible and again
you don't want them to be
um totally dependent on Parliament for
their careers for their livelihoods you
know they need some Independence
themselves so when people complain about
career politicians you think it's a good
idea that they have something else yeah
but then again I think I think the issue
is around how how much do we know about
is you know how how clear is it what
their jobs are and it's not so much the
jobs to me it's not the jobs that are
the problem it's the conflicts of
interest that are the problem and that's
where Owen Patterson you know got into
trouble because he didn't declare his uh
his conflict of interest with randox
health so it's when it's when there's
these other uh and it could be a job it
could be being lobbied it could be any
number of things that come to bear on a
politician and as long as we know what
those things are then we can figure out
well whose interest are they working in
is it the Publix or is it you know this
company that's employing them or is it
this lobbyist that's taking them out to
dinner or to the rugby or whatever Bob
Catholic when you uh in charge of the
Civil Service did you feel confident
that not just ministers but the MPS who
came to
talk to you about different issues or
talk to colleagues about different
political issues did you feel confident
that you knew their motivations and
there wasn't this kind of um the kind of
things that people worry about uh going
on well by and large I'd say yes and
just to deal directly with Derek's
question in my experience the bulk of
politicians of all parties come into
politics for the public good I genuinely
believe that but unfortunately we've had
some very high profile cases where they
transparently haven't come into politics
for the common good I'm a passionate
believer in transparency because I think
transparency ultimately brings with it
Greater trust and and the great service
to the work that you've done through sky
and and tortoise is to make it much more
accessible to the ordinary public and
that's a good thing it's interesting I
think that we can see from our panel
that there's quite a some surprising
level support for the view that actually
politics most politicians do come into
it for good reasons but let's
talk about another aspect of why I think
people are concerned about this Louise
Brown
um who I think has some thoughts about
the way it looks and feels from where
she's sitting Louise
is it fair that MP salaries are so high
well that of nurses and other health
workers are so low
why um why why is that such an issue for
for you because it's a job they we've
decided that they're going to be paid 84
000 thereabout
um
do they
nurses and health workers
um you know they're saving people's
lives and you know are MPS doing that
yeah but in this investigation uh Louise
is it is it just the money that concerns
you or is it the issue that we've been
talking about here about the sources of
of money and so on
yeah I mean well like I think it's both
I mean how do you how how is the job of
an MP worth so much more of that of
people working themselves with the ball
in a hospital and of course it worries
me where the sources of the money comes
from as well yes it's both things okay
uh Henry um
of course there's a sort of there's a
context for this isn't there that
actually at a time when a lot of people
feel that they're under Financial
pressure the country is struggling in in
various ways
whether or not it is legitimate and I'm
stressing it again there's nothing
unlawful here the sense that money is
coming from sources for reasons we don't
quite know is not good for politics is
it no I think the the public there is
there is especially in the wake of the
expenses bundle there is an absolutely
corrosive mistrust of politicians and
that's ultimately bad for for all of us
because most politicians are in politics
for good reasons they're trying to do
their best and if they can't if they
don't have public confidence then that's
a problem I think speaking specifically
to the question one problem that we have
consistently had and this actually I
think predates the the expensive Scandal
is the fact that lots of people don't
like it when politicians are paid more
money the original reason that the
expenses system became the Scandal that
it was is because basically Parliament
was using it as a way of padding MPS
remuneration because they didn't want to
raise the headline figure we've now got
to a point where MP's pay is actually
set by an independent body but every
time that independent body suggests an
increase the MPS will kick off about it
so to to speak specifically to the
question ultimately there are only 650
MPS they have quite a specific job I
actually think probably not a popular
opinion they're probably not paid enough
for the for this for the for the
sacrifices that you have to make and if
we paid them more through the official
channels there'd be less scope for the
kind of stuff that you've been
investigating
but just very briefly lastly I just want
to quickly come back to um I think we've
got Connor summer on the on the line
um and Connor I know because we've
spoken to you before Connor's looked at
the site and he has a point specifically
about what Derek Watson called double
Jobing
uh Connor good evening
good evening my local MP is also the
leader of the local Council and I'm kind
of in two minds about it because on the
one hand I think it can lead to some
joint up thinking between national
government and local government
but they are two full-time jobs and I
just wonder can one person really do
them both well that's interesting Bob
kuzler you ran a big city council for
quite a long time which indeed produced
a cabinet minister David blunkett and of
course these are now quite big jobs what
do you think I think it's a legitimate
question to ask and I think the test of
any second job or even third job in some
of the cases we've seen is to what
extent are they still realistically able
to do the job that you would expect of
your MP it's not the fact that they do a
second job it's can the two
realistically go together and you're
quite right the job of being a leader of
a council is a very demanding job I
can't say it's impossible but you're
right to say can the two jobs be done
together and that's the sort of thing
that the electorate in that MPS area
ought to be asking them James have we
learned anything this week that will
would throw light on Connor's question
are all these jobs doable I I think I
think Collins question is brilliant
because in some ways you might say look
look at the experience we've had over
the last few years the relationship
between Westminster government and local
government has felt much too separate
you might say actually Connor there's a
real Advantage for having someone who
can see what's happening nationally and
see what's happening close to home but I
do think you put your finger on the
central question around
second jobs which is around divided
loyalties or as Heather put it conflicts
of interest that can you do the job that
you're being asked to do but is there
any risk that you're being taught in two
directions at once and I think that
there are there's a separate issue which
is about the amount of money MPS earn
you know I think Henry's got a point
you'd love to have a system where you
really feel as though MPS people are
making the law and influencing the way
in which government is run are really
focused primarily if not solely on
what's happening in Westminster
Parliament and their constituencies how
much are they being distracted how much
are they seeking worker elsewhere I
think that's a real tension
Heather what do you what do you make of
it it people are rather sort of
ambivalent about this they want MPS to
be grounded but they're worried about
the money distorting their choices yeah
well I just wanted to go back to the
question about deservingness of pay be
extra big issue than just you know MPS
expenses or how much their salary is
it's it's a real societal issue and the
reasons nurses get paid so badly is
largely because they're women because we
don't value caring professions in a
monetary way we just think it's unpaid
labor that people do out of their you
know the goodness of their hearts or how
dare they even ask for a raise and you
know to me that's that's a real root of
our of our economy you know we need to
have we need to value carers and if we
you know our society is we we show value
how much money people get and if we're
not paying nurses or carers then very
quickly Bob last one yes I'd say I agree
with Heather I think the problem is not
the MP salary is too high is that nurses
salary is too low that's the problem
all right you are watching a special
great debate on the Westminster accounts
coming up
the multi-millionaire Dale Vince tells
us why he gives thousands of pounds to
the labor party and its leader
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Blevins and I'm Skye's senior Ireland
correspondent
[Music]
I'm based in Belfast a city transformed
by Pace but still struggling with its
past
politically the two sides are as far
apart as ever and it's over that
question of who has sovereignty in
Northern Ireland the varying issue
that's been the source of tension here
for Generations
it takes 60 Minutes to cross the Irish
sea it took the British Monarchy
essentially
I've spent 25 years reporting the
journey from conflict to peace
political parties of Northern Ireland
have reached agreement
we help you understand the world with us
today
we have reached an agreement with the
conservative party on support for
government in Parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to Winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
Ophelia was the most powerful hurricane
this far east in the Atlantic on record
live in a place like this and not
appreciate the environment
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing the Westminster
accounts and asking who funds your MP
well when it comes to donations to
political parties people obviously want
to know why donors give and what they
expect in return
the founder of the green Energy company
ecotricity and environmental campaigner
Dale Vince has given more than 350
000 pounds to the labor party as well as
individual donations to Kia stama and
Angela Rayner
he's also given a lot of money to just
stop oil and Extinction Rebellion I
spoke to him this afternoon began by
asking him why he gives to a political
party at all
I tend to try to support the causes that
I believe in that I think are trying to
do good in the world labor party falls
into that category I think is vital that
they have some degree of uh increased
funding to fight the next general
election because the the disparity
between them and the Tories is always so
large but I have given money to
Greenpeace uh to the green party to the
lid Dems as well to see Shepherd to
Extinction Rebellion to just stop oil to
a women's refuge in Stroud as well to
the good law project
um you know so the money that I give
that I'm able to give I'm very happy to
do to have a whole bunch of different
good causes well political parties are
special though aren't they what what do
you expect to get your get for your
money from the labor party or indeed the
green party of the lib Dems well nothing
just to help them really you know to
have the you know let's say personal
satisfaction perhaps of feeling that
I've done something to help out because
you know the green party are pursuing a
good agenda the lib Dems are also on the
Progressive side of political Life along
with the labor party and these guys need
help there's a huge disparity in funding
and I'm happy to be able to help it's as
simple as that you give money as you say
to just stop oil Kirsten has been pretty
clear that he is not on the side of the
tactics of just stop oil and others um
does that not make you a little bit
uncomfortable no it doesn't at all
kirstama has criticized uh the the
extreme tactics of just stopped well not
all their tactics but you know the
extreme end of disruption I understand
that he's not alone in doing that lots
of other people have as well and I've
got no issue with that I also believe
that the labor party will not issue new
licenses for uh Drilling in the North
Sea so I think they're actually aligned
policy wise with just stop oil and the
differences of opinion is uh you know
it's over tactics but look in life we
don't get a completely best fit anywhere
when we vote for a party in the election
um we we don't necessarily agree with
everything they've done or will do we
take a best fit approach that's normal
and I think it's the same with funding I
don't agree with everything that
Extinction rebellion and just stop will
do and I quite frequently say so
publicly but amicably and it doesn't
change my support for their overall
mission let's talk about the issue of
donations in themselves and so you will
know from the work that Sam Coates and
the sky team and tortoise team have done
what we've tried to do is to create more
transparency around the money that goes
into politics are you satisfied that
we'll
as a country in the right place on this
or do you think we need to have new
rules or a new regime or a new way of
approaching things so more people know
more about where the money comes from
and where it goes to well there's a lot
to say here right first off um I did
chat to Sam I understand that it took
several months of work to unpick the
many different sources of information a
lot of which is quite opaque to stitch
it together into the widget that does
present a searchable database I think
it's a fantastic piece of work I think
there's not enough light shown on
donations I think Sam and his team
unveiled some uh you know let's call
them shadowy organizations that have
donated quite a lot of money to the Tory
party uh for example and I think it is
wrong in our democracy that news
organizations should have to do that
right this is the digital age all of
that stuff should be online and easily
accessible then on the question of
funding I think there's a clear case for
Public Funding of general elections if
you look at this total sum of money
spent at an election it's less than 100
million pounds
is a drop in the ocean uh in order to
choose the right government for our
country when you look at the sums of
money involved if we get the wrong
government the wrong leader Liz trust
for one month lost the country more than
30 billion pounds right so 100 million
of Public Funding to keep politics clean
in general elections I think would be a
good thing to do
Dale Vince there uh we should say that
we tried to speak to several
conservative donors but none of them
wanted to speak to us
well let's uh talk to our viewers panel
they didn't want to talk to us and uh
I'll talk to Robin Gillingham Robin
you're in Devon where are you standing
on all of this
hi Trevor I just think there should be a
funding cap on these donations to try
and create a sort of Level Playing Field
for all the parties and not just give
them any Financial benefit to wealthy
bias I think this small change will give
voters a fairer sort of more democratic
outcome so um my question would be
should there be a funding cap on
donations to create a Level Playing
Field for all parties
thank you very much Robin uh Robin's
question for the panel is should there
be a funding cap on donations to create
a Level Playing Field for all parties
um Bob kerslake uh what do you think
should there be such uh a restriction
and if so where would you put it
it's a good question I personally think
that our politics couldn't function
without donations and they're not per se
a bad thing
as long as they're transparent as long
as there are clear rules but I do worry
about the imbalance of funding between
the political parties which has
increased in my experience over time and
I think there is a question about
whether there should be some level of uh
cap on that amount of money going to any
particular party unless you want to move
towards Public Funding you do end up I
think with a very significant inequality
where that should be I couldn't give you
an answer tonight Trevor but I do record
a concern if you like about just how
unequal the battle is between the
political parties
um Henry where do you what do you think
about this I didn't what do you think
about
um Dale's suggestion that we might put
um essentially an embargo on donations
around general elections and but fun
parties equally for their general
election campaigns so I guess there's
there are two separate issues on the
idea of limiting donations I think the
question is one if you're going to have
a Level Playing Field how do you define
level you know if you've got a party
such as ukip a few years ago with one MP
and you've got the conservatives with
300 and something MPS should they have
the same funding limit or should they
have a funding limit that's proportional
to their vote share and who do you
police that and the people that you end
up putting in charge of policing that
will actually have a very large role in
our democracy which is something I think
we need to take into account the idea of
Public Funding ultimately this money is
going to end up in politics one way or
another there is no perfectable system
you can't build firewall strong enough
so if you shift towards Public Funding
and capping donations what will happen
is as we see in the United States you
end up in the US they're called
political action committees you will end
up with lots of Allied groups all of
them receiving money it will be much
harder to track I know during the brexit
referendum it was very difficult to try
and track you know which Allied group
was getting donations from where So
currently the system is that the parties
get the money they declare those
donations and those donations can be
compiled into a relatively transparent
database if we move away from it that
won't be the case Heather you um have
experience of uh the United States and
Henry's mentioned that the role of
political absence committees which are a
huge business in the United States do
you think that that vitiates that that
makes the point of trying to limit uh
the size and extent of donations or
increased Public Funding pointless
because people get around the system by
setting up these other bodies
I mean the
American politics and it's not just the
political action committees
do you think there's a there's a
question of fundamental fairness around
should one person with a million pounds
uh you know be able to bring all of that
influence and then you have to have you
know 10 people of a hundred thousand or
you know it sort of it skews whose
interests are getting represented and do
you want the top slice of society having
this unequal representation in
Parliament effectively because that's
what happens when you have no cap on on
limits is that you end up with a very
tiny Elite having huge outsized
influence on our government but is that
entirely right because actually I think
we can have a look at the top 20 donors
and actually when you look at them
they're not by and large individuals
they are it's big outfits uh the biggest
donors actually are to labor unions and
unite GMB uh the co-op gives them a lot
of money and there are companies uh the
um that the people who build uh farm
machinery jcbs and all of that give
conservatives a lot of money most of
these are not the biggest donors are not
necessarily individuals I mean Dale
Vince who gives up 300 to 400 000 didn't
even make the top 20. yeah but I think
the thing is if you look at America you
can see that a lot of the big funding is
coming from a very tiny amount of
individuals and it really does skew
politics and political representation
and I don't think we want to import that
kind of stratification in into Britain I
mean at least when you have these big
groups that like you know a union or a
big Collective that's a lot of people
together giving a huge amount of money
it's not just one person okay James
there's an investigation LED you to
think maybe we should
find some way of regulating controlling
corralling the donations
so
um well this conversation is because I I
by Henry's point which is if you create
essentially a state Arbiter of who gets
what money there's a whole set of
problems associated with that and if you
don't allow for the freedom of
expression of political donations that's
a that's a problem too I think one of
the issues about the leaderboard that
you showed there that was donations to
MPS there's Auto donations to parties
and so I think the point
um that Robin was making which was about
a cap
is a really interesting point because if
you get back to First principles what
you're saying is look if you really
believe in a cause if you are like Dale
Vince you want to change the government
of the country how are you able to do
that and express that and use your
resources to do so okay fine the
question is should there be a limit to
that so you don't have as Heather says a
few individuals who have outsized
influence and we should say those
individuals then often end up in the
house of laws we've got an issue there
all right let's uh let's take this a
little further and talk a little bit
about
how we understand these donations Gareth
Kearns I think you wanted to make a
point about transparency
yeah yeah well how can the Parliamentary
process be considered uh to be at all
transparent when there's one donor who's
given the address of a debits building
there's another one that is a firm of
accountants who uh ah we must assume the
proxies of the true donor and are they
thereby maintaining the donors anonymity
so my question would be what are the
implications of donor anonymity for our
country and our democracy
this is quite a big issue isn't it Henry
I mean my poor colleague Sam uh Sam
Coates has been scouring the country
knocking on doors for uh donors whose
names are are in the record but finding
empty offices with wet carpets and all
the rest of it
it's not good no and I think I think
this is a regulatory problem now I might
it might be wrong because you've been
investigating this or not and I haven't
but as I understood it actually donor
donor anonymity is not allowed in the
United Kingdom there was a there was
actually a fury a bit of a fury during
the brexit referendum because it was for
reasons Terror related allowed in
Northern Ireland for a while and there
was a big donation via the dup to the
the pro-brexit campaign but that was
specifically allegedly because there was
a gap in the Northern Ireland I don't
think you you shouldn't be able to have
donut anonymity of that sort and if it's
currently occurring that is a failure of
the regulator that needs to be policed I
think the bank account cannot be
anonymous but we don't necessarily need
to know who we're not necessarily
allowed to know who holds a bank account
we'll just just to identify what the
what the real problems are that we've
had and it is yeah and it is a point
worth making that for all the MPS
declarations that you know our system is
very transparent it's taken a team of
people from two newsrooms nine months to
try and make sense of this I think you
know Bob kersnick's point is absolutely
right the vast majority of people there
is this public service and the truth is
that actually on the vast majority of
donors you don't knock on the door and
not know who's there actually you can
see it pretty clearly
the problem that you've got is that a
number of donors do disguise themselves
that's a problem the second problem is
the MPS report how money is given in a
bunch of different places using a bunch
of different databases and PDFs and
whatnot so it's really hard to actually
make sense of it all together I think
the benefit of the Westminster accounts
is it does all come together in one
place and then you can begin to identify
the ones that simply don't make sense
and then you go out and investigate them
and indeed I can I can say with
authority because I had to look at look
at it for to present this show it does
help a lot we're going to break you're
watching a special great debate on the
Westminster accounts when we come back
we'll discuss more about why it's so
often so hard to see who's behind
political donations
uh is anyone in there does anyone work
in there there's nothing identifying any
company whatsoever the floor looks
pretty damp there's really no sign of
life doesn't look like there has been
for some time
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing the Westminster
accounts and asking who funds your MPS
now
how does the relationship between
business and politics really work of
course money isn't the only way of
gaining influence the art of lobbying
existed since Julius Caesar Caesar got
stabbed in the Senate there doesn't have
to be anything illegal about paying
people to persuade others to do
something but right now we can't track
for certain where that money is always
coming from let's talk to Judith Randall
who I think is with us Judith you have
some concerns on
the issues of influence in general
what's your thought
yes I question the whole system when it
comes to funding of our politicians and
payment for work outside of Parliament
and peace credibility is on the line
when they make so much money outside of
parliament I have lost faith in our
political system and worry politicians
can be bought and then act in the
interests of private companies
and Wealthy Elite and I have a question
and that is are our MPS too influenced
by outside interests thank you very much
Judith Judith's question is are MPS
too close to outside interests uh Henry
we've been talking about money but there
are all sorts of other ways in which
what used to be called swagian can be
brought you know friendships not wanting
to be embarrassed in front of your
friends and so on do you think we've got
an issue with that yes I think again
it's something that can often be
overplayed I think the idea that you
know most MPS are not in hock to
corporate or other interests but you can
do non-monetary ways to influence MPS
the most obvious one is Perks you know a
nice day at the races a very nice meal
the kind of stuff that because you're
paying for it they sometimes if you can
do it through the right way they don't
have to declare it on something that
someone like James can look up appgs
which I think we've mentioned are the
most obvious examples all party
parliamentary groups basically most of
them are completely harmless they're
just they bring together politicians
from different parties on an area of
interest but the way that they're
accounted is very much a relic of the
pre-expensive Scandal era and so you can
do an awful lot of stuff or with appgs
like buying yourself nice things and
there's no receipts at the end for
anyone to check so that's really the the
Avenue that I'd be concerned about
Heather you you became famous for
triggering the expensive Scandal but
actually aside from
the Buns uh do you think that there are
other ways that we need to think about
or understand by which MPS may decide
maybe influenced uh to do things other
than their constituents interests yeah I
mean certainly there's uh that's the
main thing you want to know is influence
is what are all the influences that are
bearing down on a politician and not
just a politician but also I would say
quite high level civil servants and we
need to know what those influences are
and our lobbying law is is pretty opaque
there's there's not a lot of reporting
requirements and there's a lot of ways
that uh you know influence can be done
and it's usually in these more informal
mechanisms dinners as perks and uh and
and really it's access that's the main
thing it's it's just getting access to
these people and that's what you see so
much of this um even the donations a lot
of it is paying to access the people
that make the big decisions Bob do you
you spend a lot of time in Whitehall
indeed actually some there's something
familiar from local government in this
that actually it's not just somebody
standing people's money but people
belonging to the right circles going to
the right Golf Club being to get the
football matches or shooting weekends or
whatever it is does that we don't have
any controls over that in the United
States what they call K Street which is
the big lobbying Street in Washington
they're very very stringent rules about
who can sit do what with whom what
generally have more control on that look
I think there is a case to say it's it's
not tight enough I think in local
government actually it is pretty tight
but even there you can see councilors
sometimes getting unduly influenced by
those outside and let's face it
um the money involved is more compared
to the prizes sometimes they're seeking
to achieve changes in legislation
changes in decisions so yes there's a
constant risk and we have to be
constantly Vigilant about it like Henry
I think most appgs are pretty harmless
and do a fairly effective job but
there's always that risk there and we
constantly have to review and revise and
adapt our arrangements and controls to
make sure that we're capturing the
latest way in which influence is being
improperly done just very briefly uh
James you you probably
entirely apart from this investigation
you probably
sat in the two both establishment
journalistic jobs in the entire world
editor of the times ahead of news at BBC
but did it ever worry you that there's a
sort of
that there's a sort of sense that
there's an elite crowd that influence
each other in way that we don't
understand
yes well I just want to say one thing to
Judith which is please don't despair
about the about politics and politicians
please don't because it would actually
be a misreading the Westminster accounts
the thing that should when you go in and
you look at it what you actually see is
it's not the case that everyone is you
know looking out to make money this way
and that there as I said right at the
beginning it's actually quite a small
number of people it's it's definitely
the case Trevor that there is inevitably
a problem and it doesn't just happen in
our capital in London it happens in
capitals everywhere that everyone gets a
bit close and a bit cozy actually one of
the benefits of our system is that you
go back you go home you go to your
constituency and you try and hear what's
really going on I would say that the
real issue is the way in which the rules
of that system work the way in which the
root of our democracy work Warner more
so necessarily than money okay uh just
as uh the report what James said I think
the average amount of money that an MP
getting donations all rested is less
than fifteen thousand it's quite small
yeah actually and it is all right you're
watching a special great debate on the
Westminster accounts when we come back
how much does the lack of transparency
around money and politics matter to the
reputation of Westminster
to get change you need two things you
need momentum you also need something of
a consensus in the building behind me
quietly more and more people around here
are coming out and telling me that there
is a case for changing the rules
[Applause]
we developed a system that can detect
elephants but also humans in real life
we use a uh basically a standard
Bushnell camera it's a wildlife camera
that's being used across the world by
Wildlife organizations and what we did
is we added some of our own Hardware to
it
and that makes it now possible to
analyze photos that are taken by these
Wildlife cameras using artificial
intelligence using machine learning
we were in contact with uh different
organizations that are active in
Wildlife Conservation like WWF but also
with someone from a university of
Sterling and
um they told us that they use these
Wildlife cameras and they then they have
to go back to these cameras after like
six months to collect the memory cards
and then they can see well there's on
the photo there was like a voucher there
10 weeks ago or an elephant 12 weeks ago
and that's when we thought well what
about if you can see that information in
real time and that's how we came up with
this system
and we tested this in Gabon and now if
you deploy this camera in the in the
rainforest within minutes you know
whether there are uh humans or elephants
in the forest so but inside there is a
satellite modem uh so basically you can
deploy these systems now anywhere in the
world uh and we can alert Rangers when
something of interest is is happening in
the field so if an elephant walks by a
ranger now basically it gets a WhatsApp
notification or an SMS message and
saying uh there's an elephant detected
near this position
we trained a machine learning model
together with the University of Sterling
um that is over 90 percent accurate in
detecting humans and elephants on the
photo but obviously we can use any
machine learning model on our camera
trap so we can also use this system to
detect rhinos or lepers or other uh
other other types of animals
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing the Westminster
accounts and asking who funds your MP
now from what we've been reporting you
could say it's obvious we need more
transparency relying on a register of
members interests doesn't do that much
to reassure us about the moral compass
of our politicians second jobs donations
just part of the murky world of
political influence but there's no real
momentum to reform the system as far as
we can tell any attempts have been
piecemeal at best so what can we do to
ensure that the people elected by us are
acting for all of us let's talk to
Carlos enrich Carlos
what's your answer
oh uh it was more a question than an
answer that I was going to make but
definitely
um it doesn't look like from the
panelist that there is really a very
significant amount of Consciousness
about the problem they are all very
comfortable with the current situation
and there is a very clear situation
where these funds could
potentially be used for quick you've got
a question for us Carlos
yeah the question is how can we increase
the Integrity of the political system
okay thank you very much Carlos has got
a question which I'm going to ask you to
answer very briefly how do we protect
Integrity in politics Heather
you started all this
well when I the reason I even started it
was because I didn't think there was uh
the Integrity that that Parliament had
was based on a on a falsity it was an
illusion and once we peeled back and got
some facts we saw that it wasn't as
beatific as we thought so I think that
yeah we need to have I think lobbying is
the big thing that people that has
really damaged the Integrity of
Parliament and we need a tougher
lobbying register so control lobbying
Henry I think you need a clear and
realistic idea of what constitutes
actually problematic behavior and then
to have that overseen by a regulator you
can't police everything you can't
control who drinks in what room with
whom it's an impossible mission and I
think that it will eventually just end
up corroding politics even more so a
clear idea of what's wrong and empowered
to fix it Bob I think you've got to
recognize that trust is vital to good
government the vast bulk of MPS do a
good job and they're committed but
they're undermined by a small number who
abuse the system and you've got to
constantly work out tackling those
people identifying them and dealing with
them because I feel angry about those
MPS who do a great job and they're
undermined by this sort of issue a lot
of agreement from our audience on that
James
you've made the trouble this week what
would you actually do about it so the
the big lesson that I've learned in this
project it's been nine months has been
there's a difference between
transparency and visibility
it's one thing to say well I'm declaring
everything and it's another thing to say
it's really clear what I'm doing and I
think that in two regards we need
greater visibility we need to make sure
that the system of reporting in
Westminster not just done by Sky News
and and as a tortoise but by Parliament
itself is easily accessible to every
voter in the country and I think that's
an issue inside Parliament and I also
think it's an issue for parties so I
think I think visibility for MPS and
political parties too thank you all we
are going to return to this but that's
all we have time for this evening it
just remains for me to say thank you to
our panelists here in the studio James
Harding Henry Hill
Bob kerslake and Heather Brooke
but of course it's you at home who at
the center of our conversation and if
you'd like to get in touch with the
program you can always email us at the
great debate at sky.uk and I want to say
thank you to our viewers panel as always
who've been fantastic and uh to you at
home keep talking we'll see you again
for the great debate
[Music]
thank you